John boyega who is an actor I think he
was in the new Star Wars movies John
boyega and I mentioned this a little bit
at the end of the show yesterday is
making headlines because he said an
audacious shocking thing he said that he
a black guy only dates black women
two GQ he said I only date black
then it's about chemistry personality
goals is there a Synergy can I help you
can you help me
again it's kind of a tawdry and clinical
way to view a love affair can I help you
can you help me can we advance each
other's interests okay I love you honey
uh no let's do it let's Advance each
other's interests that's not what Cole
Porter's saying no uh not a great way to
look at love but he's saying look that's
how it is and uh and then he got in
trouble because he said he only dates
black chicks and when he got pushed back
he said when people talk about
preferring brunettes or blondes they're
not talking about wearing a wig my
preference is not a topic for debate
and I I agree with him here
why is why is it wrong for a black guy
to to prefer to date black chicks
I don't think why is it wrong for a
Japanese guy to prefer to date Japanese
chicks
why is it wrong for a White Guy to
prefer to date White Chicks oh that's
very wrong
you see because John boyega will get
away with this he ultimately won't get
in trouble
because black people can't be racist
if a Japanese guy wanted to date a
Japanese Jake he probably wouldn't get
in trouble but if if a white actor came
out and said I only date white I only
date White Chicks it would be a national
Scandal he would be certainly be
canceled from Hollywood he would never
work again he would he would be called a
Ku Klux klansman
why
why I don't see any problem with any of
that for any people
one it's
difficult to control one's preferences
not saying it's impossible to shape
one's preferences but genetics and the
way that you are raised in culture and
nurture are going to shape those things
what why is it that John boyega has to
date
uh I don't know a middle eastern chick
why does he have to date a white chick
or a Chinese chick
to advance political correctness is the
man not allowed to have the love affairs
that he wants is the man not allowed to
pick the wife that he wants
shouldn't that be the case for all of us
why do why do we have to suppress
perfectly ordinary normal things all in
the name of political correctness
I think it's fine
I I hereby uncancel John boyega John
boyega find in my book those movies are
not fine in my book but John boyega is
fun Sunny Hosten on the view is not just
attacking Trump
not even just attacking Ron DeSantis
there is a third Republican Prospect for
president that the libs are beginning to
go after that would be Nikki Haley how
are they going after her on racial
grounds
I think we've got some if they're
willing to challenge Trump I'd love to
see Nikki Haley I'd love to see Liz
Cheney I'd love to see Nikki Haley the
chameleon and Nick and Liz Cheney I
disagree I think I think that Nikki
Haley was incredibly Effective
Government
wait Alice I have a question aside from
Rhonda a lot of a lot of people don't go
by their actual room
I believe it's on I don't want to
mispronounce it it's Indian but she's
the background isn't necessarily you
know I think if she leaned into a ton of
people don't go by there
so Nikki Haley's given name is not
actually Nikki it's some Indian sounding
name but she goes by Nikki because this
is America and people speak English and
because she's in politics and I don't
know and maybe just because she prefers
the name Nikki that's fine it's very
nice name
and sunny Hosten is saying that's wrong
she can't do that she's not allowed to
take on a more English sounding name
that according to Sunny hoston
whose name is an annuncia or annunciata
or something it's a Spanish version of
of the name for the
think it's
I think it's annuncia or something no
I'm sorry Asuncion there it is so it's
not it's not the enunciation it's the
assumption but she's got a Spanish name
it's a very nice name and she prefers to
go by
an anglicized version of that
what do we take away from this two
things
has nothing to do with the names what
names people want to go by they go after
Ted Cruz for this very same thing Ted
Cruz's name is Raphael Edward Cruz but
his father in its name is also Raphael
so when Ted was a kid people would call
him philito and felito is not a name
that a young young American boy wants to
be called or really any boy wants to be
called I think and he was sort of
getting made fun of for that name and so
he went with a nickname that is part of
one of his names
a nickname for Edward his middle name is
Ted and he goes by Ted okay is there any
problem with that I don't see any
problem with that especially if you're
living in America America we speak
English for now and we we speak it at
least relatively coherently before all
the woke people redefine all the words
and so he goes by Ted that's fine
certainly makes a lot more sense than
some by somebody by the name of uh
Robert Francis O'Rourke going by Beto
it's kind of weird for a White Guy with
an English sounding name Irish sounding
name to go by a Spanish name when he
lives in America which ostensibly is
supposed to speak English but okay even
Beto whatever or sunny hosta wants to go
by sunny but Nikki Haley's not allowed
to do it Beto's allowed to go by Beto
Ted's not allowed to go by Ted Asuncion
is allowed to go by Sunny Nikki is not
allowed to go by Nikki
why
because it has nothing to do with any
principle it has nothing to do with any
names it has nothing to do with any kind
of racial politics even it's really just
because
half of those people are Democrats half
of those are people are Republicans
it it isn't even on the basis of race
Nikki Haley is Indian and Ted Cruz is
Cuban and Irish and Italian a bunch of
other things
and Beto O'Rourke is a white guy and
sunny Hosten is Hispanic
but it actually doesn't have to do with
rate it's just the Democrats get to do
whatever the Democrats want the
Republicans can't do anything right and
that's it so there's no principle here
and as we approach the 2022 midterms and
as we get into 2024 we have to remember
as these attacks kick up we have to
remember they are completely baseless
there is no reason to take any of them
seriously actually you don't have to
hand it to the Democrats it's completely
in bad faith it's all Bs just laugh it
off and ignore it for goodness sakes
they're going after Nikki Haley Nikki
Haley who I really like personally Nikki
Haley is a very moderate politician okay
and I promise you if Nikki Haley somehow
got the Republican nominee in 2024 they
would call her Ava Braun okay and they'd
probably call her Hitler they'd probably
just go all the way and call her Hitler
they would find a way to make Nikki
Haley a far right radical semi-fascist
anyone they would do it to anybody
I'm so glad you like that clip now
you've got to subscribe ring that Bell
get the notifications we'll see you next
time
[Music]
thank you